Billie lourd opening up about life after the deaths of her mother Carrie Fisher and grandmother Debbie Reynolds Billy stuns on the cover of Town & Country September issue her first magazine features since her tragic losses last year inside the glossy the 25 year old actress gets candid about coping with it all using one of her mom's famous quotes quote if life's not funny then it's just true and that would be unacceptable be real and not get too wrapped up in it just be yourself probably have something Whittier to say but she also shared how there's a lot of pressure being Fischer's daughter and carrying on her family's legacy quote I've always kind of lived in their shadows and now is the first time in my life when I get to own my life and stand on my own now I get to be just Billy just like try and just remain yourself and be true to yourself [Music]